Напівзруйновані будинки… Міни на дорогах… Втомлені та зневірені люди...
Такий вигляд має Донбас останні декілька років.
Володимир Зеленський запевняє, що вже будується "новий Донбас".
За словами президента, щоб зробити регіон, який постраждав від російської агресії,
сучасним, безпечним і заможним, потрібні особливі економічні умови.
Нам потрібна Стратегія розвитку економіки Донецької та Луганської областей,
що включатиме податкові та митні преференції, страхування військово-політичних ризиків для інвесторів,
арбітраж за міжнародними стандартами. Робота над нею вже почалася.
В Офісі президента впевнені, що створення на Донбасі спеціальних економічних умов
суттєво вплине на темпи реінтеграції окупованих територій.
З одного боку, це може бути своєрідний простір для дипломатичного маневру на переговорах
про повернення Донбасу, коли замість особливого статусу Київ пропонує вільну економічну зону,
припускають опитані DW експерти й одразу ж додають: Росія на це не погодиться, бо Кремлю потрібен саме особливий статус
Донбасу, щоб впливати на політику Києва. З іншого ж боку, за словами політолога Олексія Гараня,
ідея запитати українців під час місцевих виборів, чи підтримують вони створення на Донбасі
вільної економічної зони, є популістською, з точки зору соціології безглуздою і такою, що не має юридичної сили.
Мовляв, головна мета - привабити тих, хто мешкає на Донбасі, щоб вони прийшли на вибори
і віддали свої голоси за "слуг народу".
Зараз це отака красива ідея. Ви за вільну економічну зону? Перша реакція:
а чому я маю бути проти, якщо це спрямовано на розбудову?
Мабуть, за. Але цього недостатньо. Ви за те, щоб бути здоровим, розумним і красивим?
Я особисто за, але питання, як цього досягти? Як це буде прописано? Ми ж чуємо абсолютно різні меседжі.
Економіка іде за політикою. Приймається політичне рішення, як це буде.
Але ми не знаємо, як це буде. То Кравчук щось скаже, то Єрмак, то сам Зеленський.
Україна має здебільшого негативний досвід із вільними економічними зонами, вказують економічні експерти.
Так звані ВЕЗ вже були запроваджені у 90-ті та на початку 2000-их. У підсумку олігархи мали прибутки
та уникали сплати податків, а до розвитку інфраструктури так і не дійшло.
За словами Павла Кухти, вільні економічні зони навряд чи вирішать проблему реінтеграції та відновлення Донбасу:
як підконтрольних територій, так і окупованих. Адже держава слабка та корумпована
і не здатна ефективно адмініструвати ці зони.
Серед головних ризиків - відновлення контрабанди та ухилення від сплати податків,
натомість реальних інвестицій та створення нових робочих місць не варто очікувати.
Ці проблеми лежать повністю поза межами того, що можна зробити вільною економічною зоною.
Від того, що там десь знизите податки чи полегшите якесь регулювання, не зникнуть олігархи,
які контролювали і контролюють Донбас. Не зникнуть суди, які за хабар приймають будь-яке рішення.
Не зникнуть чиновники, які готові рейдернути бізнес або просто заважають йому працювати.
Від обіцяних Зеленським преференцій, ймовірно, матиме зиск обмежене коло людей, прогнозує експерт.
Олігархічні компанії, які контролюють природні ресурси, які мали б найпершими платити податки
і які за першої ж можливості мінімізують їх під нуль, то вони точно будуть всі там, точно вони ухилятимуться від податків,
точно ми потім недоотримаємо великі надходження в бюджет, а на виході ми не покажемо ніякого результату,
тому що скоріше за все там ні інвестицій, ні нових робочих місць туди реально не прийде, і в цьому проблема.
Загалом у світі функціонує понад п’ять тисяч вільних економічних зон і чимало прикладів успішного розвитку
депресивних територій. Але у випадку України, вважають експерти, запроваджувати такі зони варто
після реальних системних реформ по всій країні.
Наразі інвестори навряд чи прийдуть на Донбас, зважаючи на відсутність справедливого правосуддя,
корупцію, брак захисту прав власності та олігархічну монополізацію великого бізнесу.